foreign
comes from Melissa in Wisconsin she says
I've been following the baby steps and
I'm very proud of how I've grown
financially and personally I have no
debt I'm saving for retirement during
college the relationship with one of my
parents became very strained and that
parent took out a twenty thousand dollar
Sallie Mae student loan without
consulting other family members
this parent is the only person on the
loan and my name is not on it I know
legally I'm not obligated to pay it back
but morally what are your opinions on me
paying it back to this parent we've been
estranged for years due to other
circumstances and I used the money in
college for books and room and board
I've tried to consult other close
Christian friends and my counselor who
did not think I am obligated to pay it
back since this person has made very
poor financial decisions multiple
bankruptcies and is not respected
boundaries with me what are your
thoughts
fourth
I've got
I'll start you start you're you're
stuttering yes you're standing I've got
a strong feeling a lot of thoughts I do
um okay let me there's a lot of a lot of
different words we can use here
I would agree with your counselor
that you are not obligated to pay it
back morally or ethically
but it has nothing to do with the other
person's Behavior it has everything to
do with the deal that was made
they took out a loan without your
knowledge and without you promising to
pay it
therefore you do not owe it
you did not handshake you did not
verbally you did not certainly not on
paper and certainly legally did not sign
for so you're not legally ethically or
morally obligated to pay this loan
period it has nothing to do with being
estranged it has nothing to do with it
it makes it weirder it has nothing to do
with the other person's Financial
misbehavior and bankruptcies that makes
it weirder but none of that is your
fault and does not change your moral
obligation one way or the other your
moral obligation is based on your
promise that was never made by you and
so you don't have a moral ethical or
legal obligation now
if you want to be generous for some
reason or another
then we can talk about it
but it's not an obligation I I like that
you said that here's where I was
struggling with this let's say you did
Melissa let's say you did take this
money out and you shook hands hey Mom I
need some more money for room and board
and books have gotten more expensive and
your mom said great I'm going to take
out this loan this Parent PLUS Loan and
you can just pay it back even though you
don't qualify to take out your own loan
then you then you would pay it and she
ends up making very poor financial
decisions has multiple bankruptcies
doesn't matter that's right so this
external behavior is not I'm not going
to let that affect my moral cause here
um I'm with you David the reason I took
pause here is I'm thinking in my
situation if I have a parent who's
struggling
they got me through college that I'm
just torn on it I'm just torn on I would
probably try to figure out a way to pay
it back it would just be generosity
though it's not an obligation and in my
mind too it would be a
what should how does it affect your
particular life okay you have two
million dollars in checking
well write a check and pay it off right
yeah it's like buying a biscuit right
okay you have no money and you're just
now coming out of baby step three just
starting you're 26 years old and your
mom's killed you make 75 000 a year and
you know her voice in your head that you
haven't even heard in a long time in
person is guilt-tripping you uh then no
that's just uh psychological backflips
there you go you're just doing you're
just doing gymnastics in your own brain
there like somehow it's gonna make her
okay somehow it's going to make your
relationship okay that you wave This
Magic Money wand over it and
everything's going to be okay nope not
going to happen uh and so this does come
down to two things number one is are you
obligated the answer is no number two do
you want to be generous and for me if I
were in your shoes that would be
that it's not a big deal that you can
that twenty thousand dollars you're
you're a doc and you make four hundred
thousand a year now I don't know
whatever scenario we don't have our
income or her net worth here
um but uh you know I kind of smell
in the verbiage that this is a 26 year
old
making less than a hundred thousand
dollars a year and doesn't have any
money well and to add on to that this
feels like in in Dave we don't talk
about this enough we probably should the
number of parents who mortgage their
souls for the kids to go to school and
they Circle back 10 15 years later
asking kids where's my I need that money
or without without having a deal with we
never had a deal we I got you through
college now I'm looking at my retirement
hey I put twenty thousand dollars on the
line when are you gonna pay me back and
that's the same idiot though that that
um it's common that says you owe me
because I changed your diaper oh yeah
you know that's the same art you know I
fed you when you were three shut up you
signed up for that that's right you know
that's not that's just bull right there
so uh sorry Mom that's how this works
um you know but the uh um
yeah so
um a lot a lot of stuff going on here
but but I think I don't want to be the
psychologist here you're the you're
that's your job but in my mind it sounds
like
um
you probably intellectually Raj but some
part of your little girl self Melissa
wants it to be that the script is
Rewritten if you write a twenty thousand
dollar check that suddenly Mom's okay
and your relationship with Mom's okay
and that's not gonna happen and it's not
ever gonna be the same thing that house
burned yes and now you got to build
something new and if part of you
building something new is I'm gonna go
back to everybody who played a role in
my life and I'm gonna be generous to
them that's cool that can be a part of
your house that you're building for you
into the future It's Not Gonna Save Mom
it's not got anything to do it's not
gonna save them that's right this has
got to do with you that's right yeah but
it's not a moral ethical Christian
obligation that you pay someone else's
debt
that's right it's that simple and that's
what a parent plus loan is and then I
think it is good one more time let's
Circle back for the sake of people
listening because we have a student loan
crisis that is of Epic Proportions moms
and dads do not take out student loans
of any kind and do not take out a Parent
PLUS Loan and then saddle your kid with
it when they're 30 Suddenly at
Thanksgiving dinner
okay that's relationship Russian
Roulette number one number two it's
morally ethically wrong number three
it's financially stupid
okay don't do that
and so uh you know this idea that that
you know the send the kid to college at
any cost including the cost of all our
futures mine and yours we're going to
all go deeply in debt so you can get a
degree in left-handed puppetry